Abu bakar alag daddy is dead he died
like a dog and
I'm I didn't change one word of that
that's what he opened with and then he
did 40 minutes the speech is 40 minutes
the meanest talk you've ever heard in
front of the whole world
Abu we could hear him crying I said Abu
don't cry Abu let me tell you something
Abu cried he cried quite a bit I
wouldn't have
cried Cry Baby Back daddy that's what we
were all
calling that's a great Trump impression
that is so much better than the majority
of trump Impressions he did a good job
good job because because of the pause
you know a very powerful tool on stage
is stillness and Trump uses it and good
performers use it and so it's the it's
that and Trump's trying to formulate
what he's going to say